hey what's up y'all I'm Kelly Clarkson
and I play Moxie an ugly doll cheeto
pitbull mr. 305 but I said just a
worldwide and ugly dog I'm the Darth
Vader yes we are doing first our first
those we're gonna be answering questions
to one out first yeah
first big red carpet event mine is
definitely to do with Idaho obviously I
was on I don't um I want to be was a
movie premiere for may be called swimfan
and we all had to go like we were there
I don't know why it was just a very odd
thing but I mean and I shouldn't really
yelling at us you know like they do the
photographer and then I probably look
frightened and like every photo like
swimfan I think I know what you weren't
even wait now how old are you what you
don't want is that kind of woman you
suppose you're not younger than me hell
do you I'm 26
okay I'm a decade old I'm 36 oh my wife
is 36 yeah you like Google I like you
your wife she's sweet she's your wife is
awesome she fixed my makeup one time at
an event she was so nice look Sam it was
off and I was a little bit sweaty first
big red carpet we'd been small things
but first big one I think was the
Grammys we want the Grammys that was a I
mean we watched some TV grown-up and you
go there and it's just an unbelievable
experience that year we were nominated
Adele won she did all right
my first big one actually that I went to
red carpet it wasn't even about me to be
honest which I went with somebody else
so I got a chance to see how crazy it
was and that's what I don't do red
carpets not hey oh my gosh my favorite
one wait I got to sleep bike is 50 cent
I hate red carpet sometimes it is like
they always talk to me about things I
don't know like why Bernice we shave
your head I don't know I don't know like
ask her why she shaved her head I don't
know like so 50 cent came one year it's
like the VMAs with like God heard of
people like 50 no no so my little is
this for somebody I wouldn't him on the
carpet
I hid behind his people and just walked
and snuck and didn't do the Red Cross
stuff I was like I was so weird they
were just all baby
Thanks walked right in I was like I love
you but you said Kelly first memory that
comes to mind of your first American
Idol audition um switching places with
Randy Jackson and the fact that I knew
who Randy Jackson was nobody else did
there because I'm obsessed with liner
notes and I you know you worked in Ryan
Carey first singer you were a twig on a
song a lot of pressure from Nessa I grew
up listening to Stevie Wonder well jeez
yeah
I actually got the chance to sing with
Stevie Wonder dropping the name
Stevie Wonder handed me my first Grammy
he and Alicia Keys well that's a bigger
than Adrienne it was a huge thing meet
you hand me my Thursday yes I will
Steven Tyler I was obsessed I thought we
were gonna get married it didn't happen
it's fine
I love ariseth yeah we might have to say
loose so loose is assume guy
Lorena nabuwa which is the queen of Cuba
go ahead she's always up there with us
all right
first memory that comes to mind of your
first Jonas Brothers game okay so first
Jones for this gig my dad was a pastor
grown up he got another church like a
neighbouring Church to host a concert
for us and there was a bunch of people
that basically went to the church that
came and pretended to be fans first time
you realize you wanted to pursue singing
my father used to put me in a
neighborhood called Little Havana in
Miami if you see the beginning of
scar-faced and you know what I'm talking
about I said my friend yeah but he would
put me you take me to the bars and put
me on top of the bar make me recite
poems from his big port in Cuba named
Jose Marti yes I was five years old on
top of a bar so yeah
so it's totally
that's when I seen that the power of
words and I said man one day I want to
be able to get on stage
well my dad was musician as well grew up
in musical home obviously music with the
brothers all that but my first sort of
venture to music was my parents came
back from seeing a Broadway show in New
York came home and said my selfish Olin
is and there's a young boy in the show
you were stealing my story that's this
is mine late minutes I saw him brought
my own eyes not this is my statue in
your store you are stealing my memory go
ahead well this is weird
lovely not Jewish but like we the same
thing that's so great amazing oh if I
googled like your story I've never said
it okay so basically came back said you
could be in the show because you're
seeing well you love performing and then
later on in life I did the show oh no
you're just cooler no mine is mine is
oddly enough I went on scholarship cuz
it was poor but I got to mine
scholarship with our choir to New York
and we saw lame is it was my first
musical ever to see and I was like just
captivated and John Waage on actually
was my favorite character that's odd for
girls cuz usually at you because that or
whatever and I thought I want to do
something a music on stage but I'd like
to hear you sing on my own I have a few
my first song you'd ask from your
discography oh you're gonna hate me
everyone's gonna hate me
my brother signs it to be show for
Disney not which was a great what and in
that show you know sort of like the
Monkees were like the songs will be a
part of the storytelling and so there
were some songs that I think left a lot
to be desired
it's been that way and one of those
songs was called pizza girl it was about
how we fell in love with the pizza
delivery girl I don't hate the song but
what I hate is that at our shows we're
trying to play like our real songs needs
a girl and it's just let's just put that
one to rest
yeah that's we can be done with that
yeah mine oh I'm about to get so hated
here it's because the song was not
written for me it was written for the
winner and it's not necessarily some
I'll I'm not against the song I just
it's not really
that's a big disclaimer right now I know
because it's a pretty big song but it's
it's a moment like this I don't really
that's a great song it's yours I think
it's great for the moment but like I
just you know it's just it wasn't I
didn't pick it and it's not really
something I would have anyway
don't hate me or hate me I don't care
speak my truth yes I'm strapped for cash
I did this commercial I can't wait I did
this commercial for an educational
commercial twelve hundred dollars and it
had me wrapped this song said learn more
earn more it was horrible right ya know
it's crazy enough bringing it full
circle now we own schools we build
schools that's amazing that ten schools
now slam ten thousand kids so it's
amazing let's maybe maybe that
commercial led to that yeah anymore
that's there's truth to that first
embarrassing woman on stage I don't get
embarrassed that should be Ghana for you
I went on tour with Luke's Luther
Campbell with his uncle Luke from 2 Live
Crew we were in North Carolina or shall
we say North cackalacky and Luke goes
out there he goes I got this Cuban boy
from Miami and I'm Tony right now I spit
fire you don't see nobody out here or
everybody's thinking I'm gonna bring it
but before that yeah I was before that I
was nervous so I told Lucas a loop can i
honest now go ahead and hit that
Hennessy right there I said yeah knock
yourself out go boom hit the Hennessy
hit that Bacardi feel no can I hit that
Hanaka yeah he know what he was going so
when I get on that stage he's already
boost me up everybody's like yeah yeah
bring him bringing my crowd to the spit
and in my mind I'm rapping like I got
this and really what was coming out was
[Applause]
I was doing it Luke looks over to the
side and Luke says so when I get
offstage thinking that I did my thing
all right
I'm not sure they looked me out there
yeah I go to grab another be out the
cooler and I fall right in the corner so
with that said that could have been the
beginning or the end of my career one of
the best lessons of my life that's like
can't wrong notes I have and I'm just
like yeah
I guess that was today sometimes it
happens yeah for sure I've got plenty of
stories but one of my earliest stories
was was I was doing a show called the
Christmas Carol which I was the
understudy for Tiny Tim you know his
woman really my first time on stage and
the the producers never rehearsed the
kid to play tennis him because if the
kid never got sick and the eight years
of show it run so they call my parents
up to go he got sick
Nick's arm for Tiny Tim he's got an hour
to rehearse oh nice so at seven years
old I get up on stage they start the
music
and it's probably literally 16 bars of
just blank music as I'm looking at the
crowd stunned credibly embarrassed but
then it shaped who I became is exactly
because there are gonna be these moments
where things don't go to plan and you
got to be able to shake it off so it
doesn't matter I think that's why I
don't get embarrassed cuz I'm just like
well this is why sometimes I might be
funny it builds character and you're
like well Elena in pitbull first time
someone else referred to you as mr.
worldwide a grandmother who ran up on me
and said this is how I was sounded she
said oh yeah mr. world way oh this is
amazing because pitbull when it turned
on mr. 305 it was Trick Daddy that gave
me mr. 305 and then one day I did
international love of Chris Brown and me
just playing around
we had just traveled the world I just
went on tour in S&S mm for mr. 305 mr.
worldwide listen I think it's got a ring
to it
hold on so I call myself mr. worldwide
and that's how well he does little
grandmother whoever it was that day they
say oh yeah me too worldwide
we're talking mommy mmm grandmother's
called me a lot of things but nothing
this cool
[Music]